comment ça l'était des toyota camry des
fourgonnettes familial on romette des
milliers de dollars de taxes
actuellement quand on voit l'inflation
il ya parlé de toyota camry piscine trop
y jouer avec la vérité parce que
l'écrasante majorité des femmes aux
toyota camry et seront même pro touchés
est ce que la taxe sur les véhicules à
essence de québec solidaire s'appliquait
aussi largement que le laisse entendre
françois legault
non
quatre des six modèles de toyota camry
ne seraient pas touchés
[Musique]
la taxe de 15% viserait les véhicules
qui émettent plus de 210 grammes de
dioxyde de carbone par kilomètre
uniquement deux modèles qui ont des
moteurs six cylindres dépasse les
limites et c'est donc taxer le prix de
vente de ces modèles est d'environ
trente sept mille dollars
avec la taxe de québec solidaire il
faudrait ajouter 5600 dollars
si on additionne la tps et la tvq et les
autres frais qui s'applique la facture
totale grimperait à plus de 50000
dollars
l'immense majorité des fourgonnettes des
camionnettes et des véhicules
utilitaires sport serait aussi visée par
la taxe
parmi le top 10 des véhicules les plus
vendus au québec l'an dernier trois
modèles seraient épargnés parce que
leurs émissions polluantes sont sous la
limite établie par québec solidaire
trois autres le seraient partiellement
puisque certaines versions du modèle
excède le seuil et d'autres non et 4
modèles seraient entièrement axé les
camionnettes de la série f le gmc sierra
le ram est le chevrolet silverado
québec solidaire affirme que des
exemptions de taxes seraient accordées
aux familles nombreuses et assurent
qu'ils doivent utiliser leur véhicule
pour travailler le parti s'engage aussi
à remettre l'équivalent de 15 % du prix
de vente à ceux qui achètent des
véhicules électriques